[موسيقى]
في زاوية معينة من
بلد معين، يعيش
مخلوق لا يوجد في أي مكان آخر في
العالم، هذه هي كولومبيا والكلمة هي أن
جنسهم الفريد رائع
ومراوغ ومهدد بالانقراض بشكل كبير، وهو
مزيج يمكن أن يحبط عند
محاولة اكتشاف واحد ولكن  إن احتمالاتنا أفضل من المتوسط ​​أثناء السير في
غابة حارة كالساونا، وذلك
بفضل الأشخاص الذين
يعرفونهم جيدًا، فهم يحبون
رحيق
الزهور ويلصقون شعرهم، كما تعلم،
شعرهم كما هو الحال في الزهرة
هكذا وشعرهم هو شعر وجههم.
بدأت روزام جوين حياتها المهنية
كمهندسة للمناظر الطبيعية، ولكن عندما تم
تعيينها للمساعدة في بناء حديقة حيوانات، التقت بالحيوان
الذي سيغير حياتها وحياتهم،
القميص القطني، التمر الهندي، وهو
قرد صغير بمظهر يشبه دكتور سوس
وشخص محلي لطيف بنفس القدر.  لقب T
أستطيع أن أرى لماذا وقعت في حب
هؤلاء الرجال الصغار أوه نعم أنت تعرف كيف
يمكنك ألا تفعل ذلك
عندما علمت أن
تجارة الحيوانات الأليفة غير القانونية وتقطيع الماشية
وحرقها قد دفعتهم إلى حافة
الانقراض عقلها المعماري  تحولت
من بناء حدائق الحيوان إلى إعادة بناء الغابات،
وهو أمر أصعب بكثير من مجرد
إسقاط البذور
والتربة، فقد يستغرق الأمر يومًا واحدًا لقطع هيكتور
من الغابة ولكن إعادة بنائها تستغرق حوالي
20 عامًا، ويُطلق على جهدها اسم مشروع
تيتي، وعلى مدار عقدين من الزمن تعلمت
ذلك  تتطلب إعادة الحياة البرية ذكاءً شديدًا
وعلاقات إنسانية لأنه من أجل
ربط موطن تيتي المجزأ،
ستحتاج إلى الأرض وتعاون
مربي الماشية الذين لا يشاركونها حبها
لهذه القرود، هل من الصعب العمل
مع الطبيعة أم الطبيعة البشرية بالتأكيد
الطبيعة البشرية أوه، سأكون كذلك  يسعدنا أن
نتسكع مع القرود وفي
الغابة، هدفنا هو الوصول إلى
نقطة معينة حيث يوجد ما يكفيهم
ليكونوا مستقرين ونحقق ذلك على المدى الطويل،
مخاوفنا هي أنك تعلم أنك
تخاف دائمًا من ذلك.  لم تحصل على الدعم الكافي
للاستمرار، فقد شعرت بالقلق من أنها لن
تمتلك أبدًا الموارد اللازمة لشراء
قطعة أرض محورية، ولكن بعد ذلك جاءت
مستثمرة ملاك من وادي السيليكون، وهي ستيف
جوبز وجين جودل، جميعهم منخرطون في ريادة
الأعمال الذكية المخصصة
لإنقاذ حياتنا.  الكوكب الذي قلته انظر، إذا كان هناك
شيء واحد أريد القيام به قبل أن أموت، فهو
مساعدة هذه المرأة على القيام بما تفعله وهو أمر
لا يصدق، كان كريس فارغاس
داعمًا لها منذ ما يقرب من 20 عامًا وعندما
سمع أن روزام يريد شراء
مزرعة ماشية قديمة في  نقطة حيوية توصل
إلى شكل مبتكر من عمليات
الحفظ التي يتم تمويلها جماعيًا ويطلق عليها اسم "
عالم جديد" وفكرنا لماذا لا نقوم فقط
ببناء موقع على شبكة الإنترنت وبناء تقنية
تتيح لأي شخص في العالم النقر على
الخريطة واختيار فدان واختيار 10 فدانًا واختيار 50
فدانًا و  احصل على كل هذه التعليقات
عما حدث بالضبط لأموالك من خلال
تبرع لمرة واحدة بحوالي
1200 دولار، كما يقول، يمكن تأمين فدان واحد
لـ TTS إلى الأبد، وسنقدم لك كل عام
بعض لقطات الأقمار الصناعية التي توضح
إعادة تشجير أرضك والأشجار
تنمو حتى تعرف ما الذي نجحت فيه UD،
لذلك عندما تشتري أرضًا لها، فإنك
تمنحها الفرصة للحصول على
دخل ائتمان الكربون على مدار الأربعين عامًا القادمة
والذي سيمول شاحنات الموظفين ووقود
البرامج التعليمية للأطفال، وهذا البرنامج
لابني ريفر و  ابنتي
أوليفيا، هذه الشجرة لك بينما
ننقذ هذه الغابة الجميلة من أجلهم،
نحن ننقذ الغابة من أجل العديد من
الحيوانات الأخرى التي تعرفها، لذلك كل الكوكب لنا وكوكب صالح
للعيش بالنسبة لنا بالضبط
لأننا نحصل على الماء، نحصل على الهواء الذي نحصل عليه
الكثير من الموارد ولهذا السبب
نركز كثيرًا على ربط الأشخاص
بالطبيعة لتقديرها
والعناية بها ونريد أن نفعل شيئًا
حيال ذلك مع القليل من المساعدة التي يمكننا تحقيقها
لأننا نمتلك الخبرة التي
قمنا بها  هو واه
[الموسيقى]
يعمل